got my back back waxed last week about
his beautiful a Polish girl and man she
every you know some of those hair she
pulls him like you're like damn boy some
of those things I think they were hooked
into my spine you know just cure
scoliosis they this rip that thing up
and suddenly you you know you're scurvy
is healed up and I you know and where
I'm from I grew up where you remember
when they used to have the thing at
school where you would do the scurvy
test and they'd come over and they'd get
y'all in the line and it's Daniel one
after the other and then they would bend
you'd have to bend over and then
somebody would rub their hand and when I
really think about this it's really I
mean from a little bit it's erotic but
it's also very they wouldn't allow this
these days because everybody's a real
piece of [ __ ] but they would somebody
whoever the instructor or somebody who
knew about scurvy or scoliosis would
take their hand and just rub it up your
spine and I remember as I got older as I
had about sixth grade did I think I
might even you know sprayed out once
when they were just testing me for
scoliosis because I was you know I had
that there wasn't much room between that
ski inside of me and whatever was going
on in the outside world you know I'm one
time somebody scared me really bad and I
just came you know came on myself
because I've always had wild nerves and
heavy heavy nerves thick with nerves you
know I think if you looked inside of me
a lot of people have a lot of veins in
them and you know in a different you
know bones bone structure skeleton and I
know we're all operating on the same you
know the same running operating system
or the skeleton you know I know we all
the same basic template inside of us but
you know I think everybody's a little
different in there you know and I think
you know I've always had you know I've
always had small lungs and that's what
the doctor told me you know I had small
ribcage I had the rib that kind of the
the torso the inner torso the skeletal
torso of a large cat and I remember our
family met doctor telling me that when I
was young you know and I've always
but I've always you know I remember
getting scared once and just pick my you
know my penis and balls is kind of you
know just the jackal added in them up
into my pants and that was just you know
that's just me growing up and part of
that is growing pains and just being
young and feeling the vibrant energy of
being youthful but you know that I was
always right there was always just one
quick touch was gonna get me to pop off
you know some people that's that you
know when it comes to you know sex
there's a lot of different you know you
know special tactics and um common you
know common sutra met you know it's you
know a lot of you know foreplay or
vibrant [ __ ] or [ __ ] outdoors or
whatever get you you know whatever get
your marbles to to spin but for me it
was just I needed a surprise moment yeah
and that's what we really get me you
know like I thought was [ __ ] a girl
and she told me a ghost story I'd come
in a heartbeat and that's just how I am
you know that's how I that's everybody's
body reacts differently to invited to
the environment but yeah I remember that
scoliosis test man it was you know that
thing was it would turn you on a little
bit because first of all they have a
couple ladies come from the doctor you
know or whatever the doctor local
hospital or whatever and you didn't know
these ladies you know these were some
fresh ladies but what I'm saying is
these ladies become a school and they
would touch your spine and you didn't
know these ladies and you had just
gotten you know you would just I mean
when you start thinking about sex he's
and you young you get that I mean it's
just like it's like you know somebody
just put a hit of acid and you know
inside of your dick and you you know
your your penis just start seeing colors
and thinking about the future and that's
what would happen man it's armor and
these ladies would come to check us for
scoliosis and I'd be erect man I'd say I
think I got it I'm like no you don't
have it I'm like I think you got to
check again get Janet over here to check
at the same time I'm trying to you know
I'm saying I'm trying to get this sixth
grade three something going I'm trying
to have two ladies rubbing on my spine
at the
same time but I remember that was a
crazy time and when you get your back
checked out at school and you know you
would know if he had scoliosis or if you
had some kind of spine impingement but
you know when you get that back waxed I
think this lady this this lady pulled
something out I mean it just my posture
has been better since she took this one
rib and they do these little rips right
around by your bait right around by your
panty line you know right by that male
panty line you know where they they got
that hair so delicate right there my
goodness
it's like what Pharma grew these little
you know these little baby rabbits I
mean that hair right around your panty
line is so soft it's just such a softest
hair and it's almost dangerous to even
have I feel like but yeah so I got my
back waxed and and I'm feeling good well
thanks for watching that video right
there that was a beautiful little
segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe